in this video you're going to learn how
to classify numbers whether they're real
or imaginary rational or irrational if
they're integers whole numbers or
natural numbers so take this like you
would take a quiz go ahead and take a
screenshot or write these
numbers down and see which categories
they fall into keeping in mind that they
could fall into
more than one category
before we do that let's take a look
at a little decision tree here to see
what how to determine basically what
categories that a number falls into
so the most general uh category is right
here at the top where we talk about
complex numbers and if you've gotten to
learning about complex numbers this will
be easy for you if you haven't
let me just kind of give you a little
overview that a complex number is part
real and part imaginary so you can see
you've got real numbers imaginary
numbers if you've never heard of
imaginary numbers before the main thing
to remember here with imaginary numbers
is that it's whenever you go to take the
square root
of a negative number so say if i had the
square root of negative like 49
when you try to take the square root of
a number it's basically asking you what
times itself is that number underneath
the square root right so if it's like 7
times 7 that's positive 49 not negative
49. if you do negative 7 times negative
7 that's also positive 49 so how can you
really take the square root of a
negative number uh by having the same
number times itself well that's where
imaginary numbers come into play but for
the purposes of this lesson just
remember if you're taking the square
root of a negative number like this one
it's going to be imaginary otherwise
it's going to fall into the real number
category
once you determine that it's real and
not imaginary you have to decide is it
going to be a rational number or is it
an irrational number it's one or the
other it can't be both now one way to
kind of distinguish or determine is
think about that word rational see that
word ratio in there ratio means any
number that can be written as an integer
divided by another integer okay now you
might be saying what's an integer well
an integer is basically
any round number
positive negative or zero so you can see
here's a list negative three negative
two negative one
zero one two three etcetera whereas an
irrational number
might be something like the square root
of uh 43 for example
if you do this on your calculator you'll
see that this is a non-repeating
non-terminating meaning it doesn't stop
decimal okay
and so
when you have something like that that's
non-repeating and non-terminating
it's going to tell you that it's
irrational meaning this ir means like
not rational meaning it can't be written
as a ratio of an integer over an integer
so for example if i had
0.7 that's the same as 7 10. if you
divide 7 by 10 you get 0.7 that would be
considered a rational number or if i had
square root of 25
25 square root of 25 is 5 which can be
written as 5 divided by 1. see anything
divided by 1 is itself so that's a ratio
of two integers
so the main thing to remember you might
want to make a note is rational is going
to be
either a ratio an integer over an
integer or something that can be
written as an integer over an integer
and it could be like a decimal that
repeats or a decimal that terminates
and we didn't talk about the repeating
decimals but say for example if it's 0.1
repeating like
0.1111 well repeating decimals can
always be written as fractions of an
integer over an integer so if you do 1
divided by 9 that's 0.111111 like that
so
that's what you want to look out for
with rational and irrational but once
you determine it's rational
okay is it an integer
meaning like we just talked about here
it's a round number that's positive
negative or 0.
now a subset of the integers
it would be the whole numbers here and
you can see the whole numbers are kind
of like a
a part of the integers it's just 0 and
then the positive
round numbers so zero one two three four
and then if we take it one step further
to the natural numbers oftentimes
referred to as the counting numbers like
if you ask a kid to count they'll start
at one they'll say one two three four
you know
and they go up from there they usually
don't mention zero they usually don't
mention negative numbers
so what's interesting here is that
it can be in more than one category now
let me show you another diagram
that can help you when you're
determining what type of number you're
dealing with so
so you can see that this big
set of numbers here is the complex
numbers but within that you've got the
real numbers and you've got the
imaginary numbers right
and so it has to be one or the other
it's either real or imaginary right or
if it's a complex number it can be a
combination of real and imaginary but
for this video it's going to either be
real or imaginary
but say for example you determine that
it's rational like it can be written as
a ratio of an integer over an integer
well then automatically you know it's
also real because see how it's
inside of that group it's like a subset
or if you determined it was a natural
number like let's say the number 15 okay
that's a counting number it's
automatically going to be a whole number
an integer a rational number a real
number and a complex number so
this diagram can help you save a little
bit of time if you kind of realize that
these numbers are subsets of larger
subsets of larger groups of numbers so
you might want to refer back to that as
you're taking the little quiz here okay
but let's go through these now and see
how you did so let's start with number
one here so it looks like we've got
uh negative square root of 49 so is that
real or imaginary
well it's not the square root of a
negative number there is a negative on
the outside but there's not a negative
underneath that square root so that
means that this is a real number
and if we simplify it further
what times itself is 49 that's 7 then
this negative on the outside makes it a
negative 7.
negative 7 can be written as negative 7
over 1 which means that it's a
ratio of an integer over an integer or a
rational number now keep in mind it's
either going to be real or imaginary not
both and it's going to be rational or
irrational but not both so it's one or
the other
now negative 7 is also an integer
because remember we said integers were
round numbers positive negative or zero
but it's not a whole number because
whole numbers are
zero and then the positive integers and
natural numbers are just the counting
numbers like one two three four so in
this case for number one we just have
those three categories
for number two though
what did you get for number two
well it looks like we've got a repeating
number here
0.12121212 so when it's repeating like
that we know we can write it as a
ratio of an integer over an integer in
this case 12 divided by 99
which means that it's rational
and if it's rational we know that it's
real
it's of course not imaginary because
it's not the square root of a negative
number and we know it's not irrational
because it's either rational or
irrational but not both but now is it an
integer
well it's not an integer because it's
not a round positive negative or zero
number right so it's not whole it's not
natural okay so just two on that one so
for number three what'd you get for
number three square root of negative
seven
well you can see here
we've got that negative underneath the
square root sign
when you take the square root of a
negative number you get an imaginary
number which you'll learn about when you
get to algebra two or further on in your
math studies but for this purpose of
this video we know it's not real it's
imaginary that's the only category it
falls into
okay for number four what did you get
for for the number zero
well remember zero is the same thing as
zero over one right so you can write it
as a ratio of an integer over an integer
and if it's rational we know that it's
also going to fall in that real category
of course it's not the square root of a
negative number
and if it's rational it can't be
irrational it's one or the other
zero is an integer
and it is a whole number but it's not a
natural number natural number would be
the counting numbers one two three four
like that so the zeros included in the
whole numbers but not in the natural
numbers
okay what did you get for number five
with pi so you know about pi from
geometry right in circles so pi we know
is approximately
3.14159 dot dot dot dot so it it keeps
going it doesn't terminate or stop but
it also doesn't repeat
so that means that it's going to be an
irrational number not rational can't be
written as a ratio now sometimes people
will approximate pi with the fraction 22
sevenths but that's not exactly pi so
we're going to say that
pi is irrational not rational it's real
it's not the square root of a negative
number so it's not imaginary
but it's not an integer it's not around
a negative
positive
you know number or zero right so it's
not an integer it's not whole and it's
not natural so just two on that one
for number six
what did you get for number six
well for number six it looks like
there's a pattern here you've got one
zero then two zeros and three zeros and
you've got this dot dot dot that it
continues
but even though there's a pattern it's
not a repeating decimal like we had in
number two with the
0.121212 repeating so
this one is not going to be rational it
can't be written as the ratio of an
integer of an integer so it's going to
be in the irrational category
it is real though it's not the square
root of a negative number so it's not
imaginary but it's not an integer a
whole number or a natural number
okay so for number seven what did you
get for number seven
well number seven the square root of 121
you can simplify that to 11 because 11
times 11 is 121.
and 11 we know can be written as 11 over
1 anything divided by 1 is itself so we
have an integer 11 divided by 1 which is
an integer so an integer divided by an
integer is considered a rational number
a ratio of two integers so it's not
irrational
and we know 11 is not the square root of
a negative number so that's a real
number
and we know 11 is an integer it's a
round number positive negative or zero
and it's also a whole number
and it's also a natural number one of
the counting numbers
okay how about for number eight what did
you get for square root of four ninths
well this one we can simplify square
root of 4 is 2 square root of 9 is 3
and so you can simplify the numerator
and denominator separately like that
you can see that 2 is an integer 3 is an
integer and that's a ratio of 2 integers
which makes it a rational number not
irrational and we also know it's not the
square root of a negative number which
means that it's a real number
and we also know
that uh it's not an integer and it's not
whole and it's not natural so just two
two categories
okay what did you get for number nine
well this one you can see that we've got
that negative underneath the square root
that square root of negative 17 when you
try to take the square root of a
negative number we call that an
imaginary number and that's the only
category that that one falls into and
number 10 we've got a decimal .789 what
did you get for that one
well you can see that it terminates it
stops there's no
dot dot dot there's no line over any of
the numbers to show that it repeats this
is a terminating decimal which means
that it can be written
as a fraction 789 over a thousand which
means that it's a rational number
and it's not the square root of a
negative number which means it's real
but it's not an integer it's not a whole
number it's not a natural number so just
two categories on that one
so great job if you want to see some
more examples about classifying numbers
i'll put a video on the screen here that
you can watch
otherwise i look forward to seeing you
in the next video